All right.
Good morning. No, not good morning, good evening.
If that tells you anything about how my day's gone today.
So good evening. That's right, yes.
Um, it's been a hard week for me. Physically.
My knee is really, really sore, so that's draining
physically as well.
But, uh, anyway, that's neither here nor there,
but it is just reality.
We're a family. So that's where I'm at right now.
So we're here tonight to dig deeper into this idea of God,
the Son, the incarnation.
We could do a sermon each over the next couple weeks about
the father, the son, the Spirit.
We could have taken the Trinity
and then taken the three persons and the one God,
and then explain that a little bit.
But one of the reasons we picked just doing God the Son, is
because first we love to talk about Jesus.
That's always fun.
But, but also because those, those are the two, the Trinity
and God the Son, are the two biggest heresy drivers
in the history of the church.
So thought, let's answer some of those questions.
Try to get some good framework, how to speak well
of the Trinity, how to speak well of the incarnation.
So they're hard. Like we've said, these are mysteries,
but that also means we can learn to speak well
of these things and how we can grow
into a deeper understanding.
So just as a way of review from Sunday,
we looked at John one, just walked through the whole,
really, almost the whole chapter of John one,
looking at the word, the Son Christ,
and how there's this line that traced through, uh, eternally
from this, this word idea,
which we'll talk a little bit about that later.
But, but this word idea then gets identified
as the son, the second person of the Trinity,
which then we meet in the incarnation as Jesus Christ.
So that was the track of John one giving us a picture of,
yes, this is the same person of the Trinity,
but it's, it's identify.
You can see this relationship throughout with the word
and God and the Spirit.
And then you can see God the Father, God the Son,
God the Spirit in the Trinity.
And then you can see the Father, Jesus Christ
and His Holy Spirit in this kind of next level.
So that was the progression we followed.
We saw that he's the creator, the Savior.
We saw that, uh, in him was life, that
John was merely a reflection of the light.
But then we saw he's not only creator
and savior, which kind of that idea of the word move to this
idea of the word taking on flesh, John one 14,
and becoming this what we know.
Then the, the sun.
And you see that referred
to even in the Old Testament, the son of man.
Uh, you can see that as, as reference
to this second person of the trinity.
Now, that's where the, the heresies pop up is
whenever we figure out, okay, how did God the Son take on
flesh, not lose anything.
We'll talk a lot more about this later,
but this is where we get to the two natures in one person.
Uh, this two, both human and divine nature.
In one person, that's the hypostatic union.
That hypostatic word comes from the Greek word,
which which means merged in a way.
You could say it that way, two in one.
But we can't think purely merged
because it, it's, they're still distinct.
That was one of the heresies that we saw was
that those two just merged together and became one
or blended together
and create a third or anything like that.
No, there's still the divine nature
and the human nature, uh, the divine will, the human will
in one person, but again, not competing.
The human nature of Jesus was, was fully submissive
to the divine nature, the divine will of God.
Uh, the Godhead, again, mystery.
So a couple of heresies we saw, I mentioned a few there.
Jesus only appeared to be human like he was a ghost.
Uh, his true humanity is denied,
which means he couldn't die for us.
Uh, some will say Jesus was created by God.
I've said this the last couple times, still alive
and well, counterfeit Christianity like
Mormonism, Jehovah's Witnesses.
There's this idea of Jesus was created.
Uh, he's unique, he's special,
but he was created well,
that makes him lesser than God the Father.
That's not biblical.
Uh, two persons, that's schizophrenia, uh, again, blended
or that he only one nature.
And these were interesting. I
kind of ran by these pretty quickly.
Some would say that, that God, the Son
overtook a baby that was already existing in Mary's womb,
and Joseph and Mary actually
conceived a baby and Mary's womb.
And, and almost instantly, God, the son overtook that baby.
I don't know where they get that,
but that's what they would say.
That it, it took that form
or even further in that,
that there was some random guy named Jesus
walking around Galilee.
And the Holy Spirit
instilled God the Son on this man and overtook him there.
That's legitimate. People believe that.
Whether it's true or not, of course, we would say no.
Or there's that third one where at the baptism,
which this is where they go back to where the Father speaks,
this is my beloved son, with whom I'm well pleased.
And the Holy Spirit floats down like a dove.
They say, when the father says, this is my beloved son,
that's an identification.
In that moment, he becomes the son of God.
So you can see how we're trying to wrap our minds
around this idea of the incarnation.
We just, it's, it's a mystery. Yes.
But we can't find those things biblically.
We have to come back to the authority
of God's word as our source.
But what I wanna talk about a lot more tonight
and get into some, some extra notes that I have, uh,
this idea of kenosis.
So Philippians two,
I mentioned this on Sunday when you talk about Philippians
two, and you could look it up, uh, it's in there, uh, verses
kind of four through nine ish.
There, it talks about Jesus,
and it talks about the society of humility.
And he's, he's, Paul is writing
to the church in Philippi saying, you need
to have this same mind in yourselves.
You need to, you need to be humble
and treat each other like that.
And he gives the reason, the reason have this mind
among yourselves, which is yours in Christ Jesus.
What you already have in Christ is this kind of mind.
And here is what he says about that kind of mind.
It's Philippians two, and he says it this way.
This is talking about Christ Jesus,
who though he was in the form of God, did not count equality
with God a thing to be grasped.
Maybe another word would, would be like held onto clung to,
uh, one of the footnotes says a thing
to be held onto for advantage.
So he didn't consider equality with God a thing
to be grasped, held onto for an advantage, willing
to let it go in a sense.
But he emptied himself by taking the form of a servant,
being born in the likeness of men.
Now, we often stop there. We're talking about humility
because that's where we should, but,
but notice it doesn't stop there.
I wanna read this, we'll not really touch on this,
but verse eight, being found in human form.
He humbled himself by becoming obedient to the point
of death, even death on a cross.
So he even got lower than just becoming like us.
He actually died for us.
Then verse nine, therefore,
because of this, you almost think the image of a, a slope,
just thinking skiing, I guess, but,
but a slope downward where he's, he's walking this road
of humility of, of the throne of God down to humanity,
even down to death on the cross.
But then verse nine, therefore,
because of that, then you think the upward track,
as you're going up the chairlift,
God has highly exalted him, bestowed on him the name that is
above every name, so that the name of Jesus,
every knee should bow in heaven
and on earth and under the earth.
And every tongue confessed Jesus Christ is Lord
to the glory of God the Father.
So he's gone right back to where he was to begin with.
It's down in humility, but then upward in exaltation
because of his humility leading to death and resurrection.
But the question comes in that verse where he says,
though he was in the form, this is verse six,
though he was in the form of God, did not count equality
with God a thing to be grasped.
Now, hard, I get it. But that's called the kenosis theory.
And a lot of us in church history have gotten
that a little bit wrong in a sense that we, we tend to say
that, that in a way that makes,
makes him have lost godness.
That he, he set his godness aside to become like us.
So let's just walk through those verses for a second.
Verse six. You have this pre-existent Christ, right?
You see that he was in the form of God.
So pre-existent Christ before incarnation the form of God.
We could go back to the word to the Son from John one,
that then the next phrase that he defines as equality
with God, right?
So there's an equality between the son and the Father.
Then in verse seven, you have him taking the form
of a servant in the likeness of men, just like the form
of God term in verse six, doesn't mean less than God, right?
He's equal. This phrase, form of a servant.
Likeness of man does not mean like less
than human in any way.
It means equal with all humans.
So he was fully God
and fully human, even in just these two verses.
God is very God, God is very man.
That was some of the, the creed language we saw.
But in between you have this phrase, he emptied himself.
And that's the question. So I, I don't think,
we shouldn't think that it means he became less than fully
divine is not fully God in some way.
He didn't empty himself of deity.
And I mentioned this on Sunday, the Colossians two,
nine verse where it says in him, in Christ,
in the bodily form, the whole fullness
of deity dwells bodily whole fullness,
not just deity dwells in bo in the body.
The whole fullness of deity dwells in the body.
So he didn't empty, he didn't empty himself.
If anything that would make up deity, make up godness.
He, he didn't set any of that aside.
The best clue comes probably from John 17, five, how
to think about this emptying where Jesus says in his prayer,
John 17, his prayer to the Father says, father,
glorify me in your own presence with the glory that I had
with you before the world existed.
So he's identifying, I was there from
before the world began.
I was in this trinity, beautiful communion
and have always been and was at the throne of God.
I, I wanna be back there. That's the glory that I've let
kind of set aside in a sense to be here.
So this, this incarnate Christ has a divine nature.
He's fully God, but there are aspects of his glory
that he would have laid aside.
That's why he's saying here in John 17, father, restore
to me the glory that I have with you from
before the foundation of the world.
So that would include then
at least the privileges, right?
That's what we saw. The, the quote said,
or the footnote said, a thing to be held onto for advantage.
So that would include like the privileges of deity
that stand between the divine Christ
in all the fullness of God.
How that stands between that and the suffering and shame
and death of the cross.
Like there's something between there that has to be kind of
set aside in order to get there.
He moved from such height
to the shameful degradation on our behalf.
Paul says in Philippians two,
that's the same mindset we should have towards other
people, right?
The same mind that Christ had
and having this incarnation from glory to shame.
We should have the same as we look to serve other people.
Okay? So then what do we mean? This, this?
We gotta qualify that. 'cause it would be a mistake
to say he set aside all the divine glory
because part of the nature of God is glory.
So he's still the divine nature.
So how does it still, how does he still have some glory,
but not all the glory that he had?
Because John one 14,
remember the word became fleshed, dwelt among us.
We've seen his glory.
Glory as of the only son from the Father
full of grace and truth.
So there was a divine glory, even in the incarnate Christ,
for people to see if they had eyes to see it.
But it couldn't be the full glory of God.
Because what would that do to sinners,
Incinerate, sinners, the full glory of God,
no presence of sin.
Just immediately they would be
incinerated it blinded people.
We saw a glimpse of this.
Think about Jesus on the mountaintop.
When he's transfigured, Peter, James
and John get to go up on the mountain with him.
Jesus lets them have a glimpse of the full glory
when he is up on the mountaintop,
because he's shining, he's glow, right?
There's a, there's a difference to Jesus on the mountaintop.
Then there was day to day that was a measure of showing them
some of the things that were restrained in a sense there.
So here's a, again, a better way to say it.
Whatever stood between the fullness of the divine glory
before the incarnation and the suffering and shame
and degradation and death of the cross, whatever stood
between there that had to be a laid aside so he could do it,
but nothing having to do with his divinity, his godhead,
his God, nature, none of that.
So that would say hopefully some of the answer to
that question, a little bit of
what did he set aside when he came?
It wasn't any of his divine nature,
because that's what that image was
of Jesus sleeping in the boat.
Remember where there's this massive storm raging around him,
and he's on this open canoe, essentially just napping
The professional fishermen over here freaking out
because they don't know what's happening.
And they're like, we we're gonna die. Don't you care?
And he's sleeping human, yet
he's stands up, says one word.
Everything stops. Only God can do that.
Human divine in one person. Okay?
Now here's another question. I actually got this one already
this week and want to address it.
The omnipresence of God. Okay?
So if God didn't have to limit himself in,
in any real divinity kind of way to come to earth,
still fully God, what about his omnipresence?
Because Jesus is one location seems right.
He's a man walking around like,
I can't be in multiple locations at once.
Only one location.
You walk up to Jesus, you touch him, you see him.
That's, that's seeming to limit God.
The son's omnipresence, all presence.
He's present everywhere. 'cause the Trinity, right?
God, the Father, son Spirit is all yes, omnipresent
in its essence.
But what about the son?
What about Jesus taking on the flesh?
What, what happened there?
'cause we think about the incarnation, we think about
Christmas, baby Jesus being born and right.
So it's clearly a miracle,
but does it limit his omnipresence?
Well, one of the attributes
of God we looked at a couple weeks ago was impassability.
Impassability is a long word
that simply means God doesn't change.
So if God doesn't change
and he's omnipresent,
that means he still is omnipresent even
as God the son incarnate.
And you're like, okay, wait a second. How?
Okay, yes, let's try to answer that because he's impassable.
God cannot be omnipresent.
Yet here we have Jesus.
So for Jesus Christ
to be God incarnate must not mean he was no longer
God omnipresent.
He, he has to still be omnipresent even
as God the son incarnate.
So remember, the divine nature does not go any,
it does not undergo any essential change in the incarnation.
Still, God, the Son, still fully God.
All the divinity fullness of God dwells bodily.
So still, all of God still there.
So what is he talking about? Well, again, we said it.
Philippians Institute didn't exploit his divinity
to leverage it against the fullness of humanity.
He fully experienced humanity like you and I do,
but he didn't void his deity.
Again, this is the mystery of this.
So he, he, he emptied the glory.
And so he did not employ all
of the divine abilities at his disposal because,
'cause if he, because subtracted those somehow,
then he wouldn't be fully God anymore.
So somehow he's subtracted, but not subtracted.
He just chose not to employ.
So here's the, here's the alternative.
If he's not both incarnate
and omnipresent at the same time, then we either have
a lesser incarnation on one hand
because he's not fully God, then,
which means he can't fully satisfy the sin
that we have against God.
Or we have a lesser godhead on the other side,
that he's not fully God
and that means he's not able to be God.
So, so we have this option, the alternatives
to not omnipresent
and incarnate is that, here's
how John Calvin said it way smarter than us
for even if the word in his immeasurable essence united
with the nature of man into one person, we do not imagine
that he was confined therein.
Here's something marvelous.
The son of God descended from heaven in such a way
that without leaving heaven, he willed
to be born in the virgin's womb to go about the earth,
to hang upon the cross.
Yet he continuously filled the world even
as he had done from the beginning.
Wow. So here's what he's saying.
And it's hard for us because we think in space
and time, right?
We, we only think in space
and we, we have no concept of outside of time.
We have no concept of omnipresence 'cause we're limited.
So we, we have to understand God's incarnation in Christ
was not an exit from heaven
so much as a descent, like down the ski slope, an a descent,
a extension, you might say
that even, uh, in John's gospel, he says, so Christ
who is in heaven
clothed himself in our fre our flesh.
So in a sense, you could think like he stretched out his
brotherly hand to us.
So he may raise us to heaven with himself.
Now, that again, blows our minds
because we, we think, we think location,
but he merely extended himself to take on flesh so
that we could be with him forever.
'cause again, the son is sent, he's co-equal
with the father mutually in dwells the Father
omnipresent as the Father.
He, he's not leaving the Father.
God the Son doesn't leave the Father and do his own thing
or, or move through space.
Because remember, heaven's not like a location
that we could find in the universe, right?
We can't go searching through the galaxies
and find heaven somewhere.
Heaven is, is the spiritual reality of where God is.
And that supersedes time and location.
So it's not like the son left
a location like Amarillo, Texas
and came west to head to the mountains to go up to
Los Alamos, New Mexico.
He didn't leave a location, leave his father behind.
'cause again, Jesus himself says it,
I'm in the Father, the father's in me.
So that relationship never separated, never left.
In fact, there's still one, it's an extension in a sense
that he didn't get further away from the Father
as he drew closer to us.
He who sent me is with me in that way. Okay?
So we're gonna get to some questions here in a second,
but I want to, I wanna use one of the, uh,
the famous catechisms Catechisms are, uh, explanations
of the faith in simple terms, kind of q, q and a question
and answer type setups.
And I wanna walk through three of these
because it helps us understand God incarnation
both divinity and humanity in that.
And it helps us talk about our salvation rightly too.
When we think about salvation,
when we think about the trinity and we think about the
incarnation, we can't just think about like these
theoretical ideas.
We think about salvation.
We should, that the trinity is essentially about salvation.
Now, the father plan, the son executed, the spirit confirms
then the two natures.
In one person of Jesus, you think about the, the reality
of his godness means it's acceptable sacrifice.
His humanity means he counts for us, right?
So that's this's all about salvation
in the end when you think about it.
But these are the, the three questions,
and I'm gonna read, just read 'em
and kind of let, let 'em sit on this.
What kind of mediator and deliver should we look for?
One who is a true
and righteous human, yet more powerful than all creatures.
That is one who is also true God,
true and righteous human who is also true God.
That's our mediator and deliver.
We should look for now why The second next question.
Why must the mediator be a true and righteous human?
God's justice demands that human nature which has sinned
must pay for sin.
But a sinful human could never pay for others.
So that's why it's important
that he's true, righteous human.
Then he counts for us
and he's the only one who could do that.
But why must the mediator also be true God?
So that the mediator by the power of his divinity
might bear the weight of God's wrath in his humanity
and earn for us and restore to us righteousness and life.
So only a human can save humans.
Only God can bear the weight of God's wrath.
That's why we look for must look for a mediator
and deliver who is a true
and righteous human, yet who is also true God.
That's the beauty of the incarnation to nature's one person.
So I know there's a ton of questions about
that tr come on up here.
We're gonna talk through some of those as we get together.
First, be thinking about questions as we go forward.
I'm gonna put him on the spot a little bit tonight,
but I would say you have the opportunity
to ask some questions as well as we go forward.
All right? Okay.
So I've already preempted him a little bit on these,
but I'm gonna surprise 'em too.
Thanks for being up here.
We should had chairs like this for everybody, these chairs.
This is great. Are these are nice?
Feel kind Of weird. These are comfy.
I'm ready to not sit in it though, by the way. So, okay.
So when we think about this, um,
some of these are already like, um,
we've answered them already.
They're sort of obvious,
but just helpful was God the son's origin in Bethlehem
Was So, was God the son's origin in Bethlehem?
Yeah. No, I mean, I think it is,
we would say God the Son has always existed.
Okay. Right. In that relationship, we see the relationship
of the Trinity from, we talked about that last week.
Mm-Hmm. Right. Some, I think it was last week
seems like a long time ago.
But, um, in that, that relational component
of the trinity always existed
and we see the, the flesh we see'em take on
flesh in Bethlehem.
Absolutely. Um, but certainly he, he existed as God the son.
Yeah. For eternity past. Good.
It's like word son Christ.
We see that progression from John one.
So then, uh, what was Jesus' role in creation?
Because Hebrews one talks about Jesus
and it talks about him being the one who sustains creation.
So was so was Jesus involved in creation?
I think we see, we see evidences of that certainly in, um,
in cautions where it talks about in Him all things were
created and he, he is still a sustainer of all things.
And then the, we talked last week some about the poor
pronouns also that we see in, uh, Genesis,
particularly at the, um, in the narrative in Genesis one of
creation of man when God says, let us.
And so we would say yes, that,
that Jesus very much was a part of, of all of creation.
But, but we see that most notably in creation of man.
Yeah. And if you wanted to get super technical,
you can say that technically Jesus Christ
did not exist before Bethlehem.
But you push that too far
and you start to get into some problems
because even Paul talks about Jesus
having pre-existent.
So like 'cause Right Word Son took on flesh.
We know Miss Christ. So, so to our minds,
our visual pictures Bethlehem, Jesus Christ
is when Jesus Christ began, so to speak.
But Paul looks at it as if it's all connected,
that the Christ is the Son, is the word.
And that essentially the pre-existent one Jesus,
it's Christ as well.
So you could, you could try to split that hair
and try to get technical.
You're gonna get in some trouble probably there.
So just even as we say like,
'cause that's where people have actually pushed back.
It's like, well, Jesus didn't exist before.
Like why are we talking about, uh, okay,
Jesus is the son, is the word.
So you could try to split that, but you have to be careful
and, and realize that when we say Jesus preexisted this,
this theology behind is what we mean.
Right. Okay. Um, did Jesus ever sin?
No. No. Okay, here's the follow up.
Was he capable of sinning?
So I think the,
the word would be no, he had flesh that felt the temptation,
but his full deity, he was incapable of sin
because he is, he is holy and righteousness.
He is holiness and righteousness.
And so I think we see that as he, he took on
that he took on flesh in the same way we took on flesh.
He had a, a, a flesh that was created, um, by God.
Um, and I was reading some other things thinking about the
same way that in some ways God created Adam in the
flesh, right?
And so, um, but Adam wasn't also fully God.
And, um,
and so we see that Christ had those same experiences we read
in the, in the desert of his temptations that he faced.
And yet in his deity, he was able
to walk perfectly that perfect life.
Yeah, that's a, that's not a trick question,
but it is kind of a tricky question.
Um, because there is these two natures in one person,
the divine nature we know could not sin.
Um, James talks about that, right? Could not be be tempted.
So the divine nature absolutely could not have.
But this is where the, the rub
with the human nature comes in, is that could he could,
could the human nature of Jesus sin, could it,
could he have sinned?
And in, in one sense, there's a lot of debate about this.
You could read a lot of things,
but in one sense, you have to say kind of yes
to the extent where he would then identify with
our temptations.
But the difference for him is he had this
perfect human nature, not tainted by the sin of Adam.
'cause he wasn't the seed of Adam, right?
You look at Romans, it's all about the seed of Adam.
Is is part of why we are fallen and broken too.
The seed of Adam was not in Jesus
because he who was his father, it wasn't, it wasn't Joseph,
it wasn't a physical human.
It was the divine mixed with the
human flesh, offspring,
seed of Mary.
So in a sense, you would say yes,
but his human nature perfect as it was,
was fully submitted to the divine will.
So his human will fully submitted to the divine will
100% of the time.
So could he have sinned?
No, because his human nature was always submitted
to the divine nature
human will submitted to the divine will.
So there's a sense where he, he could not have, if
that's true, if you're always submitted to the will
of God, you're not gonna sin.
We can't do that. But the human nature, that was not seed
of Adam could but you, you can.
So that's where Hebrews four,
we don't have a divine priest who's a great high priest
who's unable to sympathize with our weaknesses.
He knows what it feels like to be tempted, like he said,
the, the wilderness scene walking down the streets
of these cities where there'd be prostitutes,
there'd be open sexual activity happening.
You don't think Jesus faced the same temptations we face,
just turned on the tv, right?
He didn't have a phone in his pocket,
but he faced the temptations we faced and yet didn't send.
So it's a bit of a trick e question.
Um, but, but there is that sense.
We have to have him being human to identify with us
and be our sacrifice.
But he cannot be anything
but divine at the same time so
that he could be the substitute for us.
So good, good stuff. Alright, so what do you have?
What questions do you have about these things?
We've got two mics up here.
You're gonna stump us at one point or another.
So we'll say that. Honestly, it's a mystery.
Unless you have a question that you want to ask,
if nobody else is gonna ask, you can ask them
And see what they say. So
Jeff's coming up with a question.
I got one question a couple weeks ago in Nicaragua from one
of the students asked, so if, if Jesus was born and Mary
and he grew and was born to Mary and their blood mixed
and our sin nature is passed through the blood, then how,
how was he, how did he escape that
Our sin nature is passed through the blood?
That was the, that was the uh,
Yeah, That was put forth in the question. Hmm.
Interesting. Well we would say that,
that it's the sin nature's not passed through the blood.
It's through the seed, right?
Through that it, it's a bit of a physical element,
but really it's the spiritual element
that goes all the way back to, to Adam in that sense.
Yeah. Good, good question. I love that.
Apparently there was, Chris
Duran was in Nicaragua last year.
They had a lively debate about the Trinity.
Yeah, it got a little hot, a little fun. So
Yeah. And that was
kind of, I think that,
and also that, I mean, right, this,
it is not a biological passage of sin.
Sin, the spiritual sin is a spiritual burden.
The sin of the human nature is a, it's a spiritual burden
that we, that we faced and that was what we talked about.
And that it wasn't the, that there's well, there wasn't a,
Jesus wasn't half Mary and half Holy Spirit.
Right? He was created by God in Mary's womb. Yep.
That was kind of, yep. Alright, go ahead Jeff. Yeah,
I did wanna go first 'cause I asked a question last week.
Yeah. Hit it. And
The goal is not to stump, this is one
of my favorite topics to seek understanding
of both the Trinity and Christ's hypostasis and,
and knowing will will never fully get there in these bodies.
But that pursuit that elevates his majesty and who he is
and how he's both able as the divine
and relatable as fully man is kinda where my head's at.
But on the, the Peck ability of Christ, the topic of was,
was Christ able to, to sin, um, both being fully man,
uh, and fully God adjacent to that.
Would you speak to Christ's faith
fully, man, relating to our experience as humans in the,
in the full capacity.
And we as people that are our faith in Christ,
is, is is supreme right?
Is the most important. So for, for understanding how he can
as that full deity relate to us, what is Christ's faith?
What's the, was he was he,
is it Hebrews 1112 talks about like he's the founder
and perfecter of our faith and, um,
but talk, talk about kind of adjacent
to his, his sin ability.
Talk about Christ's faith. Hmm.
Good, good question. Yeah.
Hebrews 12, looking to Jesus, the founder
and perfecter of our faith, who for the joy that was set
before him, endured the cross, despising the shame
and is seated at the right hand of the throne of God.
So the founder and perfecter of our faith.
So founder would be, you know, the starter, the beginner,
the creator you might say, of our faith.
Uh, meaning it is what is founded on as well.
And the perfecter
of it means our sanctifying process along the way.
So feel free to jump in
whenever you are, 'cause this is a hard one.
But, uh, I think
you look at like Jesus in the garden the night before.
He is crucified to us, it seems like there's this wrestling,
there's this, this struggle.
He has to place his faith in the divine will.
Um, and I was reading a lot about a lot
of things over the last week.
And that was part of it was, was he truly struggling
to place his faith in his father's will, his will, right?
The divine will. And there was debate on that.
There was some that were saying no,
he wasn't actually struggling with that.
He was struggling with the weight of the divine wrath
that was about to come upon him.
And 'cause he, he knew like he, he was not surprised.
Like he wasn't surprised.
He, he didn't set aside his omniscience either,
even though it does seem like he, he did.
But he, he knew the divine wrath was coming.
So how we relate to that then is this, this measure
of seeing hi in his perfection
as a human will fully submitted to the divine will.
That's where he, his faith was, was tied with his will.
Not mine, but yours be done.
Even the Lord's prayer, right?
Uh, your will be done on earth as it is in heaven.
So when we think about our faith, it's,
it's exactly the same language in a way where we're saying
to God, we want your will to be done in our lives.
We can't do that perfectly like his human will could
with his divine will.
We, we can't. But,
but our growth in perfection of faith is that same idea.
'cause coming off of 11 in chapter 11 of Hebrews,
there's all of these stories of faith
where this one and this one and this one.
And they, they were faithful and they, they saw this happen.
They saw this happen. And,
and then go read 11 tonight, Hebrews 11,
It comes to the end and he says, what shall I say?
All time will tell time would fail
to tell Gideon Barack Samson, Jeff,
the David Samuel the prophets, they,
through faith conquered kingdoms, forced justice,
obtained promises, stop the mouth,
the lines quench the fire escaped the sword made strong came
might in war, put for armies to flight.
Women received back their dead from resurrection.
That was all great.
Some were tortured, refusing to accept release so
that they might rise again to a better life.
Others suffered mocking
and flogging, even chains and imprisonment.
They were stoned. They were in two,
they were killed with a sword.
They went about in skins of sheep
and goats, destitute, afflicted, mistreated
of whom the world was not worthy,
wandering about in deserts, mountains
and dens and caves of the earth.
All these though, commended for through their faith,
did not receive what was promised since God had
provided something better for us, that apart from us,
they should not be made perfect, complete.
So the faith is acknowledged in what God did
as those like Abraham, Isaac,
Moses, Gideon, David.
They said, God, your will be done. God did amazing things.
These others also said, God, your will be done.
And they got cut in half. Therefore,
verse one of chapter 12,
therefore since we're surrounded by so great a cloud
of witnesses, let us also lay aside the weight and sin.
Let us run with endurance the race set
before us looking to Jesus, the founder
and perfecter of our faith.
Mm-Hmm. So he's saying he's tying that to the example
of those people saying they,
their whole life was God, your will be done.
Not perfectly. 'cause we know David's story,
we know Abraham's story, the mess
that Moses was right, we know that.
But they're commended for saying, God, your will be done.
So in that image of Jesus human nature saying
your will be done, divine will, that's an image for us,
for our faith as well. Anything,
Yeah. That's a, that's
a great,
that's a great thing to think about deeply.
And uh, when,
as you're asking the question I was thinking about, um,
in Romans 10 where it says that faith comes through hearing
and hearing through the word of Christ.
And there's that, there's that element of there.
Think about like having faith, but also exercising faith.
So faithing in faith, almost like a verb. Mm-Hmm.
And for Jesus to, for us to see him exhibit that.
And it took him taking on the flesh then
to experience those things of the, the temptations,
the threats, the attacks, the, um, being forsaken
to, to exercise that.
And he had it perfectly. Mm-Hmm.
And, and I think, um, we talk about like exercising faith.
So our faith grows as we face those temptations.
Now obviously, if our faith comes from hearing the word
of Christ and he, he is the word that he had, he had
that perfectly, but then was able to, um, in the flesh
see it work itself out.
That's that's pretty, I mean that's a, that's like a,
aspirational is not even the right word,
but it's like kind of where we would hope to go.
Yeah. It gives us, it gives us hope. Thank you guys.
Can I ask a follow up
question since nobody's behind me, right? That one
Nobody stated at this way, nobody's behind you go the back
Line. Yeah. On, on on, on
the same vein. I, I I agree.
Like Christ fully man with this perfected faith
and what that, um, enabled him to, to model for us.
Mm-hmm. Similar or may maybe related to the kenosis theory.
Think the, the garden in, in Gethsemane
and Christ saying, you know, let this pass I,
I'd I'd like this, but have confidence in
your will and submit to that.
I think that's a, a great example
specifically in his ministry.
We see, I've not done exhaustive look at this,
so there's probably examples.
But seeing the power of Christ's faith in his life,
like in, in his physical time here on life
with a lot of his miracles.
This, this is out there and, and definitely a non-essential.
Um, but did the power come from Christ the man
or did he have perfect faith that God would,
his will would be done in those moments.
Many of the miracles are, it's your faith
that healed you and Jesus just speaks.
And the the first one with the, the storm, right?
He, he just says, calm the storms.
And scripture says, and they stopped it.
Didn't say he made them stop.
Um, are those examples of his perfected faith, kinda like,
he's like kinda like in the garden where like,
is is there a possibility that it wouldn't
or his faith was so, so perfect And,
and what that translates to us as people is in those moments
of affliction and trial and struggle
and when we pray in faith, but we are limited
and we have doubt and fear, right?
And, and those kinds of distractions, does Christ
like, are those good examples?
Like he, what is able
through Christ the man having an example of perfect faith?
That's good. That's a good question. I'm wanna sit down
Because I don't, do you
ever need to go have a cup of coffee?
Yeah. Cup of coffee with Jeff Mann, go
Talk to this guy. Um,
great. That it's, so we, we,
we read one example of where they, um, well,
examples of, so the question is,
was it Christ's power doing the work
or was it his perfected faith and then God did it.
But in a sense it's the same power, his
God Cheat code, right?
It's God cheat code. So here's what,
Here's what I think He
Would say. No, he wasn't
fully man. He was man f**k. Right?
Yeah, Yeah. So that if we think about,
we talked about the essence of God, of our triune God,
that there's that there, there, there aren't three, right?
There's one and there are three persons,
but there's one God.
And so the, the, the power of God to do for those things
to happen is the will of God.
Um, he was able through his perfect faith
to pray perfectly in the will of God.
We don't have that ability 'cause our faith isn't perfect.
We pray, we might pray for, for healing in a person
or for, um, a change in a situation.
But that's not God's will.
And yet Jesus knew the perfect will of God
and he perfectly submitted to God's will.
And and we can say we submit to it.
And yet we in our, in our flesh, it's, there's a,
there's an imperfection in that.
Um, and so when we see,
and he promised that as we, as we pray
and we ask in faith, the faith of a mustard seed, right?
That those great things that the mountains would be moved
and we would see the will of God at work
when we're in line with God's will.
And so that we, we just don't know it.
And yet he, he did know it
that he was, he's in a cheat code.
No, but it was natural because that was him.
It wasn't like he wasn't, he was still God in the flesh.
He was manifesting at, not in the, in the weird way, right?
But he was displaying deity through flesh and,
and perfection through flesh.
And so he, yeah,
Yeah. John 16, 24,
until now, you've asked nothing in my name.
Ask and you'll receive and your joy will be made complete.
He's saying that to people. So he also says, um,
in the Sermon on the Mount, Matthew seven,
where he is talking about, you know, giving gifts based on,
you know, I'm a good father, don't give snakes.
And you know, you ask for a fish, they give you a serpent.
And he, and he, he talks a number
of times about asking Courtney God's will.
So I, I think that was a good part, is
that his human will is always submitted to the divine will.
So he knew perfectly in every situation.
But for us, we can assume in a moment
that this is God's divine will for this person to be healed.
For example, when we, we had in this church,
James five, we pray for healing.
We don't know if that's actually God's will in the moment.
We, we pray that it is, we pray in faith that it is,
but he perfectly understood
and knew that it was in this moment.
'cause he didn't heal everybody.
He knew that this person and this person
and this person out of the 15
were the ones that he was gonna heal.
And that would be the best for his kingdom purposes,
for his glory to be shining brightly.
Why was this man born blind?
Well, so that the glory of God might be shown through him.
We don't know that yet.
We can't tie the miracle to merely his humanity
either, because there are
instances where somebody like Peter's shadow
fell on this guy and he got healed, right?
Like there's so, there's, there's something going on
spiritually here that they get touched or a handkerchief
or whatever it is, and things are, whoa, God's working.
You can't attribute that to us, to humanity at all.
That's only God's divine work.
So even in the human will submitted to the divine will,
he's still in a sense tapping into the power
of God, who it is God.
But, but as, as an illustration for us,
tapping into the power of God
to see something at work in us.
So do we not pray with enough faith,
mustard seed, mountains move?
Do we not pray according to the will of God,
as rightly as we should?
That's why the scriptures matter,
because this is the will of God, right?
We, we know that he's already revealed to us these things.
And so we, that's why on Thursdays when we meet
for prayer at 12 on Thursdays we pray scripture,
we're just praying verses we're praying Bible passages.
'cause this is what God said he's going to do Now, when
and how that's up to him.
But for this situation, I look at this,
I think this passage, I'm gonna pray that.
And that's where I think we can trust that God will work
when we have the faith growing for what he wants.
Divine will delight yourself in the Lord.
He'll give you the desires of your heart.
Psalm 37, 4, the key is delight yourself in the Lord.
He'll give you the desires of your heart
because he's gonna change your desires to what he wants.
He'll answer those according to his will.
Great questions, Jeff.
Anybody else or else?
We're just gonna have to keep riffing it. I dunno. Off top.
Okay, we got it right here.
Probably don't, we probably won't have time tonight to
probably approach this too much,
but the, uh, Westminster confession of faith
and God's ordination of sin, are we gonna approach those?
Uh, because it really ties into this discussion tonight, uh,
very much in terms of what was the purpose.
And the only thing I can come up with is
tied back to the two greatest commandments and that's love.
And that we have a choice to love God and love people.
And that decision requires the will
or the choice of
sinning or loving.
Yeah. And so that's a deep subject,
but are we gonna approach that at some point?
Yeah. This Sunday actually, it's uh, it's a perfect segue.
So this, this Sunday's topic is humanity.
So we've gone from revelation to God, attributes,
Trinity, God, the Son.
Now it's about humanity.
Like we need to understand humans, mankind
in what God has said.
And that's a foundational rock.
Because sin,
because image bearers,
because identity,
you look at what's our world all about right now,
like you can see how this is a foundational rock for us
because then we understand why are we here,
what are we created for?
How do we relate to God, what went wrong? All of that.
So we'll get that this Sunday
and actually the next week too, the next week is salvation.
And we're gonna talk about just what is salvation like?
So these are big rocks, right?
These are really key, key elements.
But one thing I just as a preview for this Sunday,
there's boy, it's a Latin term.
I have to, I've got on my notes over there,
but there's this progression of
like, I'm gonna mess it up so I'll get it right Sunday.
But like, there's a progression of
when you look at the fall and Jesus,
and there was a time where we were able not
to sin and then
after the fall we're not able not to sin.
Jesus was not able to sin in a sense.
So one day we're again able to not sin.
There's some kind of like progression along the way
and it's all these Latin words, simul, tus
and like, it's just long things.
But, but that's sort of the idea is
that when the fall happened, when sin came,
we're not able not to sin anymore.
But Jesus without the seed was able not to sin
and was actually not able to sin
'cause of the divine nature in a way.
So you can see that there's, there's a sense of him
restoring what was originally created
and remaking us into that image which we originally created
to reflect now perfectly will again, someday just
progressively better now.
So that, that's a long rambling towards that,
but we'll get there Sunday a little more directly.
Good. Okay.
So nobody else has a question. Last question.
Why does this matter? Why, why does this,
why is the incarnation such an, why is it a big rock?
Why is it so important? Why do we need to grow,
like Jeff saying grow in our understanding of this?
What is, what's so important about this that it really is
so mysterious, the trinity and this so mysterious,
but what, okay, what's the point
of us understanding this idea better?
Well, I mean it's So many.
Well first of all, it the way, when we marvel
and we think deeply
and we, we approach the end of what we can understand
with our minds and step into faith about
what God's word said in the miraculous
hypostatic nature
and union of Christ, it glorifies God in our own minds.
It also sets us apart as Christ followers.
Like Jesus coming, God, coming to earth
to take on flesh is what sets Christianity apart.
It's what makes our faith, the faith, the faith
that he has given to us a true faith, a true saving faith.
And so to understand the truth about that
allows us to not only glorify God
with our minds and with our hearts,
but also to speak well to other people about it.
And to understand that he is the way,
the truth and the life.
And no one comes through the Father, except through him.
And why is that? That's because he is the father
and he came to earth and he was the only one.
That's one of the things we talk about when we, when we walk
with, uh, deacons going through the process.
They, we, we have all our deacons that are in the,
in the candidate process, do a doctrinal question list.
And one of the questions about the hypothetic union,
it's one that everybody, we, we kind of smile about
because it's to, to write that out
and think about that is good and it's hard,
but it's, it's what allows us to be redeemed to our creator
and restore into our creator.
And without the incarnation, without a true
and right understanding of it,
if we step off into the ditch on either side,
then it doesn't work out.
And so if, if Christ, uh, hadn't perfectly,
fully taken on flesh
and wasn't a true, wasn't truly in the flesh, then he,
he, he wouldn't have been able
to fully make the sacrifice for our sins.
And if he wasn't perfect, it wouldn't have been a complete
sacrifice for our sins
and it wouldn't have fully, um, Satisfied
or made atonement for God's wrath, made atonement
for our sin in God's wrath and been our
perfect propitiation.
And so to, to understand it well, to be able to speak well
of it inside and understand it,
but then to speak well of others, allows to others,
allows us to, to make that distinction where, um,
others might be.
Uh, if, if you don't have a complete understanding, then um,
you can deceive, you can be deceived, I think
into, into, into a, a false teaching, a false religion
or something short of what the true gospel is.
Yeah, one of the, this goes
to last week a little bit too with the Trinity.
One of the realities in our day is trying to humanize Jesus
so much because we want him to relate to us
like we want to relate to him.
We want him to feel what we feel.
And it even pulls God down a little bit too in the trinity.
But why should we want him to, to be a buddy?
We can hug and in a sense he is that
he's the guy who came near to us,
but he's not, he's not just that either.
And so we can't humanize Jesus so much
that we miss out on the fact that he is both God and man
and, and all that God is.
He still is.
And so, yes, that is the beauty of it,
that he is able to just like in the gospels,
so many people just coming up to him and hugging him
and like just sitting with him
and John leaning against him at the table
and whoa, yet the God
of the universe, right?
That's, that's him. So in the desire, this is
where we get in the ditches, in the desire to humanize him,
we can pull him down from where he actually is
and we don't, we don't want that.
He could be both like we, we go either or so often.
He could be both and it can, it can work out.
All right, so we got some resources down here.
I wasn't here last week. Uh, thank you guys
for taking care of that.
Um, this one on your right,
this stack over there is the Trinity resources.
So there's a lot of books there that you can, uh,
you can take a look at that would be
helpful a lot by Fred Sanders.
I mentioned him in the email.
He is the foremost scholar on Trinity right now.
So that side is about the trinity
and this side over here, this on the left is the, uh,
god, the son, the incarnate resources that you might, uh,
want to take a glance at and,
and purchase if you want to,
somewhere at your favorite bookstore online usually.
So, um, that's that. So come take a look at those.
We'll be around asking questions,
but, uh, we gotta be done here as the worship team
begins there evening after us.
So lemme pray for us. God, thank you so much for your grace
and love exemplified in the incarnation
for God so loved, not just loved in such a magnitude way,
but God loved the world in this way.
So like this kind of way
for God loved the world in this way that he sent his son
only begotten the beloved
That whoever believes would not perish
but have everlasting life.
Lord, I thank you for that love. You are love.
And so remind us even tonight, how, how good
that love is yet how mysterious
that it took God man
to, to make it a reality where we could be
delivered from our sin and made sons and daughters.
So that is true.
God, we should be so stunned by this doctrine,
of course, the mystery of it,
but so stunned by the, the truth of the gospel.
Jesus Christ, our Lord shed his blood
to cover our sin
and to take us one day home with you forever.
Guys, we look at in a couple weeks, we, we look forward
to the day whenever Jesus Christ
splits open the eastern sky
and walks into this heaven's and earth
and remakes it into the new heavens and new earth
and makes us new and takes us home.
Everything that you are on
that day, you are right now.
You were from before ages passed.
You're the same yesterday, today and forever, Jesus.
And it is a mystery how that looks with a person
here on earth for those 33 years.
But God that stirs worship.
So help us to speak well of these things
that are mysterious
to understand even just one step to tonight,
one step forward, that you would be more
supreme in our affections, in our hearts, our loves,
our desires, that our desire would be
for your will to be done just like it was for Jesus.
Even when that means it's hard
and it's a weight your will be done on
earth as it is in heaven.
Help us, God, holy Spirit, you,
you are in us as believers.
You bring about a
growth, this perfection of faith,
and to bring confidence, to bring assurance.
Remind us daily of these truths for your glory.
And in Jesus' authority we pray. Amen.